good evening most New Yorkers most
Americans could tell you what they were
doing on September 11th when they first
heard the news about the tragedy at the
World Trade Center
most of us were glued to our TV sets and
radios for the awful hours and days that
followed praying sympathizing agonizing
but removed from the chaos some New
Yorkers some Americans were not so
removed and our speaker tonight Dennis
Smith was one of those a member of the
New York Fire Department for 18 years
Dennis didn't stay glued to his
television set that day he hitched a
ride down to the site that morning with
fellow firefighters from the local
firehouse and stayed for six weeks
helping in the overwhelming task of
rescue and recovery but he didn't merely
dig and lift and carry he also listened
listen to the voices of the policemen
the rescue workers and most especially
the firefighters who were searching for
the victims - many of whom were their
fathers their sons their brothers and of
course Dennis wrote recording the voices
the stories the incredible examples of
courage and fortitude he witnessed that
September 11th and the weeks that
followed hailed as the poet laureate of
the New York Fire Department because of
his seminal work report from Engine
Company 82 published 30 years ago Dennis
Smith was in a unique position to
understand and report the particular
feelings the firefighters and other
rescue workers shared since report from
Engine Company 82 which was a
best-seller translated into 13 languages
Dennis has written ten more books in
1976 he founded firehouse magazine the
largest circulating magazine for
firefighters in the world he serves on
the board of several organizations
dedicated to helping and supporting
firefighters including the foundation
for American firefighters which he
founded another Viking author John
Steinbeck said this in his acceptance
speech for the Nobel Prize for
Literature the writer is Della
to declare and to celebrate man's proven
capacity for greatness of heart and
spirit for gallantry in defeat for
courage compassion and love I can think
of no more apt description of our
speaker this evening please join me in
welcoming Dennis Smith
thank you so much Claire standing here
before you today is nothing like
anything I've ever done before talking
about all my previous books to me was to
convey something of an entertainment but
not all books are meant to entertain
some are meant to instruct as this one
does but most fundamentally I want this
book to help our country in remembering
already our media seems more concerned
with legitimate stories like the failure
of accounting firms to accurately report
the finances of large companies and
frivolous ones like which actor or a
talk show hostess is being paid 16
million dollars a year but which is
coming out of the closet it is just a
short elapsed period since our country
was attacked and it is not yet time to
backburner our future and so if you will
honor this book by its consideration I
can promise you that you will never
forget the story it holds it's our
history yours and mine
and our children's when thirty years ago
an editor from a major publishing house
called to ask if I'd be interested in
writing a book about fire fighting I
thought of myself as an honored young
man of 29 years of age I had written a
letter about Irish poetry that had been
published in the New York Times Book
Review and I was fortunate that an
editor of The New Yorker had seen it and
assigned a writer to interview me for
the talk of the town section of the
magazine the article was published under
the heading of fireman Smith and I was
again most fortunate in that it was
noticed by an editor at a publishing
company who then thought to ask me to
write a book about the work that we
performed in the world's busiest
firehouse that book report from Engine
Company 82 went on to become a
best-seller and was translated into 13
languages now after having spent three
months writing report from Ground Zero I
again feel most honored but not because
I was asked to write this book dianna
has come in the experience
of Ground Zero Deanna has come in being
side-by-side with great men and with
great women who rolled up their
shirtsleeves heavy gloves on their hands
and knees
searching for 2,800 victims in the
attack on the World Trade Center on
September 11th 2001 several firefighters
and I had commandeered a city bus after
the South Tower had collapsed and we
made our way over to the firehouse
staging area on West 67th Street as we
headed down the West Side Highway a
lieutenant ray wick rose and stood in
the middle of the bus brothers he said
they'll see things today we shouldn't
have to see and there will be things we
might think we should attend to but
listen up whatever we decide to do we'll
do it together we'll be together and
we'll all come back together boys this
was the first indication that I was
among exceptional men on this day we
arrived at Ground Zero just minutes
after the collapse of the North Tower
men and women were still walking in
dazed circles being directed to safety
by first responders it was cloudy with
the thick and choking smoke of collapse
and we could see perhaps half a block in
front of us on this one of the clearest
days of the year walking down West
Street was like walking on a peculiar
Beach where each step kicked up a small
floating cloud of grey powder there were
hundreds of thousands of sheets of paper
scattered everywhere as if each piece of
correspondent was a leaf on the ground
of a woods in a northeast November it
was quiet except for the voices of
firefighters calling out for victims for
the survivors for anyone the managing
Chiefs of the fire department were
huddled together in a spontaneous
conference at the spontaneously
organized command post in such
circumstances the post was nothing more
than the huddle itself and these brave
men immediately realized what was
confronting them and the great tragedy
they were living through as each second
passed there they are
chief Nigro chief
chief Haden chief Visconti and the
others all coming to terms with the
horrible fact that the chief of
Department and the first deputy fara
Commissioner of the fire department Pete
Gansey and Bill feein have been killed
and recognizing that the management of
the worst attack in our history is up to
them at first I had no intention of
writing about what I was living through
my only reason for being present at the
site of the World Trade Center was to
add a hand to search for survivors to
fight the fires to pull holes and lift
debris a few days later I wrote an
article for the New York Times op-ed
page it mentioned the names of friends
who were lost in the desolation we all
felt in the midst of devastation every
firefighter and police officer in Port
Authority police officers sensed in
those first days that there would be
survivors that a piece of steel would be
lifted in a crowded elevator of still
living victims would be discovered that
buried voices from among the first
responders 343 firefighters 23 police
officers and 37 Port Authority police
officers would be heard 401 men and 2
women but there was only silence and an
occasional body in time the mission
changed from search and rescue to search
and recover and then everybody found
full or partial seemed a victory even
today going on six months later there
are almost 2,000 victims more than 150
firefighters who have not yet been
discovered and the chances of
discovering them diminishes every
passing day the site will probably be
completely cleared in May the site may
then be cleared that the memory and the
day to day effect of the most murderous
attack on innocent Americans will not be
cleared in any way the events of
September 11th omnipresent in American
life and will be for some time in our
future they remind us daily of our need
to be resolute and vigilant in fighting
terrorism from wherever it emanates the
press may want us to forget and want to
other things but they have no regard for
history and Americans will not forget
the most important day in our lives
maybe in our country's history
when President Bush got up on that truck
with that retired firefighter Bob
Beckworth and told the gathered rescue
workers that the world hears the voices
of ground zero he in that very moment
became for the first time the accepted
president of all Americans helmets hard
hats and badges gave the president a
legitimacy the Supreme Court could not
and since then he has led with a prudent
understanding of the defense and the
safety needs of our country
I say safety because the president knows
as all first responders knows know of
the possibilities of chemical and
biological weapons of mass destruction
there are evil people in the world
training youngsters to kill themselves
in the name of some fanatical
abstraction they hardly understand and
as we have seen it is only the first
responders who stand between the
consequences of the evil actions of evil
people the firefighters the police the
emergency medical technicians the nurses
the doctors but always it is always the
firefighter or the cop who is first to
arrive and it is he or she who must
place themselves in the middle of an
evil act and try to save as many as
possible
and that takes education training and
the support of our government I think
President Bush understands that singing
god Bless America and flying flags are
not new to us we have had men and women
giving their lives in previous times for
the protection of our freedoms and I
think of them often and I wondered if
our young people the MTV generation
would be up to protecting our country
with the same character and backbone
that triumph over Germany and Japan and
so many years ago and then came 9/11 and
we found ourselves to be as tough as we
dreamed we would be in adversity we were
right there not only with the first
responders at Ground Zero but in the
unprecedented outpouring of moral
outrage and determination manifested by
all Americans this moral courage UNAM is
our most fundamental weapon in fighting
the evil that has arrived on our shores
from the al Qaeda training camps but I
have not written report from ground zero
to remind us of the consequence of evil
rather my aim has been to record the
acts of great men and women men and
women who have given more than anyone
had a right to ask them to give and the
courage and determination of the
families they left behind it was written
to show the world how the character of
hardworking Americans at ground zero has
solidified the will of an entire country
and it is written to remind us of how
the courage and determination of a few
can inspire a whole world to think about
peace and how we must man firm in its
defense you know those of you in the
audience who have studied literature and
know that Aristotle said after a
sustained dramatic moment you must have
a comedic relief and there's also
another literary concept I'll tell you
about it's called the deus ex machina
which means when there when you're at a
loss for words you depend on this
machine of God and all I can do is
promise you unless the machine of God
works and God appears on the stage to
tell your joke there's really nothing
funny to say but I wanted you to see
that before I continue on with this
story because it conveys in in in
multimedia way the extraordinary
humanity of these people I want to read
just a couple of sections to you from
the book three actually and then maybe I
could take some questions if that's
possible the first is the testimony of
Mickey Cross who was a lieutenant in an
engine company 16 and he was caught in
the tower in the North Tower when it
fell well 110 stories fell and
miraculously 12 people survived that 14
people survived that I'm sorry 12
firefighters a police officer and a
woman it was an incredible miracle here
is Mickey Cross on the morning of 9/11
I'm on the phone with Christine and the
third alarm comes in to which were
assigned I try to soothe her a little
bit before leaving by saying
don't worry it's a plane but it'll be
okay we'll have to go now I'll talk to
you later I hung up the phone and off we
want went I was monitoring the
department radio at that time as well
but I still wasn't 100% sure what was
going on I told the driver this is his
driver of his fire engine please don't
use the tunnel that goes on the Battery
Park because I was afraid of God knows
wat that we could be flooded or maybe
the building had fallen on the other end
I don't know what so we got off on the
East River Drive and went south against
the traffic it looked like a movie scene
where the monster was coming from the
river and everybody was screaming and
running and tripping it was exactly then
that the second plane struck we were
directly under the tower on Church
Street coming from south to north and we
got showered with this debris it was
like being in a meteor storm and I
didn't think we would get off the block
that we would get killed on the block
right there things were hitting Bing
Bing BAM over your head the siren was
going and I had the radio to my ear so I
didn't know it was a plane that hit it I
thought it was the original building
exploding it was chaos I told the
chauffeur Ronnie just get out of here
and find a hydrant I figured we go to a
safer area when we went about three
blocks away and saw an open fire hydrant
I had a very good show for a very
experienced guy we got off the rig and I
had a little pep talk with the guys
right there in the street it was
something like okay guys this is gonna
be tough it's going to be tough but it's
another fire the main thing is we just
stay together and watch out for one
another I was trying to impress upon
them to watch out for each other and I
try to keep our heads about us you know
I was afraid of panic that was the
thought in my mind we were ordered to
the lobby command post of One World
Trade Center in the feat in the
confusion I forgot which building was
one I didn't know if it was the North
Tower of the South Tower as we were
approaching things are falling from the
sky maybe a hundred yards away I seen
the number one on the northernmost Tower
and I thought well thank God at least
now I have a place to go I know where
I'm going there it is number one my mind
was directed on getting in that Lobby I
didn't even look around the men told me
things were coming down by
bellowing around us all I wanted was to
get in that Lobby safely with the guys I
did see a body in front of the building
I think it had no feet
I remember that I tried to ignore that
because I realized that he was gone he
was also burned and we couldn't help him
I don't remember who was there except I
remember seeing Commissioner bond Essen
and he looked very distraught I think I
said something to him quickly in passing
I don't remember what I tried to say
something if uplifting but I think I
said something stupid like you're gonna
have a tough day
I remember feeling very embarrassed in
all the craziness that's going around
I'm going through embarrassment about
what I said a chief told us to team up
with the next engine company that
entered the lobby and go up together and
take three lengths of hose between the
two companies I thought it was a good
idea he said to report to the 23rd floor
and the find the command post would be
set up there as we headed up stairway be
the center of the building the core of
the building the men told me that the
elevator shafts were open and the doors
had blown out and the elevator pits were
full of bodies I never saw that I saw
injured people in the hallway coming out
of the stairs on stairway being mobs of
people were coming out some with skin
hanging off clothes burned the shovelled
a lot were just very common walking with
a determined look to get out of here but
it was pretty hectic and I did have a
concern about how we were going to get
up those stairs when I was told where to
go I just kept my mind on that one point
I didn't want to distract myself with
anything it was hard enough keeping a
sense of grace under fire you might say
and that was what I was trying to
maintain as we went up I found it wasn't
so bad the people moved out of our way
and it was one line going up one line
coming down it worked out pretty well
people were very good about it and we
were encouraging as we were going up
saying nice things and they offered us
water we were encouraging them telling
them that they were doing a great job
just keep the pace going we got up to 22
and we made a few stops along the way I
didn't want to bring everybody to clog
up the command post on 23 the guys were
pretty tired at that point after
carrying up the helmets the gear the
boots all that hose the equipment the
extra bottles they were pretty exhausted
and we hadn't even begun to fight yet
aren't even near the fire yet which was
truly truly believed we were going to
attempt to put out that fire when I got
up to 23 it was kind of quiet on the
floor very dark I saw some firefighters
moving around but not any command post
of Chiefs the hallway was full of debris
so I got there I realized I saw the
elevator shafts the doors of the walls
had probably blown out and I had to
climb over this debris to get to the
other side of the hallway here I was a
little concerned about falling into the
pit I thought God what if I get sucked
in for some reason what if there is some
kind of low pressure in the shaft that
creates a wind coming down and it would
suck me in because of the venturi
principle I've been told that the
command post was on the other side of
the building so I went there and looked
around I didn't hear anything in
particular the radios were going there
was a lot of communications but as I was
going by the elevators for the second
time the section of the floor I was on
started shaking and I said oh god it's
the elevator shaft
I thought the elevators had cut loose or
whatever and something was coming down
the shaft so I thought this section of
the floor was going to collapse and that
really kind of shook me up I didn't know
then that it was the South Tower going
down I thought it was a localized thing
and that was that but it was soon over
so once I got beyond it I felt okay I
saw that everything was all right and I
pursued looking for this chief at the
command post finally I found him and he
said evacuate the building
this was serious there was a fire up
there on top
there were people thousands and yet
we're told to evacuate so I began
heading down staircase see there's a
large african-american woman coming down
the stairs with a gentleman I wish I
knew who he was he stayed with her he
was quite a heroic figure this guy we
could have just taken off but he didn't
he stayed with this woman her name was
Josephine they were all alone and there
is nobody else in the staircase when
she's barely able to move because she
has something wrong with her feet I had
I was looking for the chief now for
direction I had her and I had this man
and I realized that they were never
going to get down the stairs like this
she may have had a heart attack or
something on the way she might go
unconscious he will not be able to deal
with her to handle her so I say to her
otice their way be with him I knew there
were people in that stairway that could
help him she wasn't going to help if she
stayed in stee they went then I saw the
chief he was not a big man and I didn't
know what chief he was but he told me
everybody out and then I headed back to
staircase B I remember seeing one of my
guys in the hallway and telling them get
out of the building he had that look you
know like what do i do what do I do it's
just that moment of time at some point I
don't know who he was and who would kind
of stuck in this predicament I reached
over and said to a lieutenant I met
what's your name I remember him looking
at me with a nice smile and saying Andy
and I say to him
I'm Mickey and we shook hands across
this woman that was in front of us that
second where you smile at each other it
was kind of neat it was the last thing I
remember until the rumble started then
suddenly there was this loud loud noise
overhead there's a sense of tremendous
energy like being on a locomotive truck
with a train coming at you that kind of
feeling just tremendous energy I think I
surmised that the building was coming
down though I wasn't a hundred percent
sure I don't know what happened at that
point my next memory is being on a
staircase next to a railing the railing
was to my left so I must have been on
the inside of the staircase and I
remember crouching down as low as I
could get I was thinking of my situation
what should I do what can I do what do I
have that is positive what tools do I
have anything that has been in my hand
now was gone my big light was gone the
survival rope was gone the only thing I
had was what was in my pocket or clipped
to me the main thing I had was my helmet
I remember thinking how important it was
that I had my helmet that was the biggie
that helmet holding onto my helmet
because I had forgotten to snap my
helmet and the wind is powerful trying
to lift it off my head there was a
fierce wind it was actually lifting my
body and pulling the helmet off my head
it's almost moving me so I'm holding
onto the helmet and I'm thinking damn I
taught probe's at the probationary
school for two years and I always made a
point of saying to them snap the helmet
you don't want to lose your helmet you
really don't want to get in a situation
without the helmet
with no head protection you're in big
trouble so here I am with an unsnapped
helmet Here I am the teacher and I
started getting hit with things
something heavy came down on me because
it cracked my flashlight so something
was mighty heavy I figured well that's
over I'm a dead man and I remember
feeling that I don't believe this is
happening I'm going to die in the World
Trade Center another feeling you know I
was angry I was a little angry I don't
know what happened to Andy at that time
we were together but then we separated
there was a lot of change over because a
lot of the guys were helping it's not
like you took one person all the way
there was a lot of switching on and off
that's why I guess Josephine ended up
with other firefighters these fellows
from ladder 6 I'm down in this little
Crouch position and there is this noise
and debris and fierce wind and the next
thing was silence
no more debris no more noise no more
wind total silence incredible sounds and
then darkness within a few seconds eight
to ten seconds darkness I didn't know it
at the time I wasn't counting but they
told me it took ten seconds to come down
after all that tremendous energy and
noise silence in ten seconds and there I
was I was okay I was waiting for the
next shoe to drop that is a story that
the story goes on and on
because there was much more that happens
in that Tower and but Mickey Cross that
survived all of those men who were
caught after a hundred and ten stories
came down on them those 12 firefighters
one police officer and one woman so if I
did it was a very beautiful thing the
way they told the stories each of them I
want to switch now from day one to day
41 a lot happens in the intervening time
but I just want to give you a sense of
this book and the best way to do it is
to do it this way
it's October 21st I stopped on the way
to the site to read a plaque that has
been placed on the side of a modern
building on
corner of 23rd Street and Broadway in
the shadow of the Flatiron Building it's
a simple plaque that lists the two names
of the 12 firefighters who perished on
this spot in 1966 and I wonder why there
is not a monumental bronze statue out
here but then I remember that the
mid-60s was a period during which the
city was tea reading rapidly and the
power brokers in New York would not have
a mindset to build great commemorative
statuary still even this modest plaque
has the power to inspire a thought and a
prayer I meet up with Lee ILP and Chief
Marty McTeague at the site and we are
shortly working in the middle of a pit
25 feet wide and 20 foot deep not far to
the north of where the golden globe
stood John Sokka is in charge of the
recovery operation which suddenly
changes from ordinary to intense when
multiple bodies are discovered I am on
the slope going down into the pit and
chief Sokka hands me a big yellow bucket
for the body parts which are handed to
me one by one a scalp an ear and arm I
wrapped them in a yellow plastic bag and
I put them in this bucket
the firefighters a cutting elevator
cable and chief sulker throws down a
pair of goggles for the man using the
partners Thor another man though
intercepts them and puts them on I find
it humorous because if he was actually
the backup man the goggles would
actually be useful as it is the partner
saw operator is throwing up a steady
stream of sparks and he has nothing but
the steady blue eyes to protect him it
is reassuring to observe Chiefs soccer
at work he doesn't miss a single thing a
single trick watching over and under the
cat and every firefighter in the pit the
objective is to remove a misshapen
stairwell that has stuck like a
building's foundation in the debris for
they have found four five six
firefighters in and around it Lee ILP
sees that he can get under the stairwell
platform only if a crane lifts it a
little Lee wraps a thick woven metal
cable around the stairs as a crane line
to which to tie it is guided down the
crane pulls and struggles so much that
it seems if it snaps all eternity will
loose the platform has finally lifted a
little maybe 9 inches but it is enough
to lead a slide under the stairs and get
in position to pull a body out chief
Fellini is above me watching the
operation with chief Pete Hayden and
about 40 firefighters the time passes
slowly and I stand there holding my
footing on the slope as the bodies are
carried out on Stokes baskets flags
draped over the remains one after
another the bodies come up out of the
pit and I reach for each Stokes basket
along with the firefighters from rescue
4 and rescue to a ninja man from the
burrows we passed the body from one to
the other like a bucket brigade from the
bottom of the pit to the flat of the
mound above the process takes an hour of
passing and waiting passing and waiting
make certain she saw chaos that only men
in fire helmets carry the body no hard
hats Sokka is ensuring that if there's a
long-distance camera trained on us they
will only see the unique helmets of the
firefighters carrying out their own
fallen brothers cross in the expanse of
West Street up Vesey to the morgue rows
of men and women all the way saluting we
have taken out as many as nine
firefighters today though by the middle
of the recovery I can no longer count
the number does not matter for each is
important and there are so many more yet
to find it is simply progress Lee ILP
tells me that it could be 12 at least
chief Hayden told me it could be 12
because all the body parts we found it
was a good day on the way out of ground
zero past the roar of the machines and
the hustle of hundreds of men and women
firefighters cops iron workers Teamsters
construction workers of all trades I'm
thinking now only of the firefighters
there are thousands of victims and I
think of them all the time but
firefighting is what I know and so are
reflect on these 343 men who were killed
in these piles who were prepared to go
into the twin towers strengthened by the
many previous confrontations with the
unknown it's not easy to walk or crawl
into a situation when nothing definite
can be anticipated apart from the fact
that there was something wrong something
seriously out of the ordinary there's a
fire could be large could be small it
could be sucking desperately for oxygen
and waiting to leap over you if you open
or it could be innocuous run-of-the-mill
fire in a chair or stove but could be
eating away at the very floor where you
stand any building can have a crack in
the ceiling any building can fall down
so that's in the middle of the second
section of the book and now I want to go
to day 68 November 17th store the end of
the book
in the meantime I'm on the board of the
New York police and fire widows and
children's fund and through the book you
will see how I am involved in raising
funds for the great generosity for this
charity which is benefitting by this
great generosity that's coming from most
Americans and I asked this Kevin shade
to go on the Today Show for me one day
to help raise money Kevin Shea was a
hero is a hero of a firefighter who
comes from ladder 35 Kevin Shea of
latter 35 appeared on The Today Show
this morning I had asked Kevin to do the
New York police and fire widows
children's benefit fund a favor
by appearing on the program and telling
his own extraordinary story as well as
presenting these beanie baby rest dogs
rescue and courage to the television
audience rescue encourages two little
dogs that we had that I had made a deal
with the with the beanie baby company
and we got a hundred percent of the
profits and so far as up to today we've
raised over two million dollars with
these little beanie baby dogs it was
gratifying to see so many of these
little puppies in the hands of the
tourists who stand outside the NBC
Studios when the Today Show airs
Kevin gave the show a rationale to
present the commemorative toys and
because of his goodwill we will no doubt
receive many contributions for our
efforts to sell them Kevin shook Shay's
story might be the most blessed of all a
young men just just 34 Kevin is the only
surviving member of the entire 9th
battalion which responded to the World
Trade Center on
day one of the 33 who died 11 were from
Kevin's firehouse flat a 35 and engine
40 when he was pulled out of the
wreckage from the collapse of the South
Tower he was barely conscious and with
three fractures in his neck and a
severed thumb he was discovered lying
between two burning pillars and had no
memory of the collapse he remembers only
going into the fire and then waking up
in a New Jersey hospital bed with his
family in the room in any National
Defense emergency situation there is a
civil defense plan in place that
suggests a response for every
contingency the plan for the world trade
tower was to take wounded emergency
workers police and military personnel to
pre-selected hospitals on the New Jersey
side of the Hudson this would not only
prevent overloading at local hospitals
but would ensure immediate attention for
wounded first responders kevin was taken
by police launched across the river and
then by ambulance to the Newark Medical
Center and there the doctors worked
feverishly to repair the voll convert
the broken vertebrae in his neck with a
donated Pattillo bone from someone's
knee kevin appreciates his fortune and
has dedicated himself to do anything
that helps the brothers and their
families but this sensitivity is not
merely a response to the events of
September 11th a year ago with his
brother Brian
Kevin founded a website called fallen
brothers comm which reports on a line of
duty deaths of firefighters all over the
country and it sells t-shirts that
commemorates them and then the profits
from these efforts go to the widows and
the children of the firefighters when
the sky grows dark at the end of the day
and as each week in month closes
September October and now November I
have to ask myself how I personally can
come to terms with this worst attack in
our history I think naturally of the
question that most people when
discussing this tragedy ask what makes
people run into buildings that everyone
else has run out of the answer can be
found only in something called character
and that takes a lifetime to develop I
can't speak for the police officers
institutional culture but I did live in
a firehouse for 18 years and I am
familiar with the elements that bill
the courage and determination that
enabled men to step into danger there's
a shared historical memory that is in
the atmosphere of every firehouse in the
city and it both preserves and renews
the culture of the firefighter the fires
and the then the funerals of brothers
who have been killed in the line of duty
are discussed over meals in the kitchen
along with the softball hockey and
handball games all part of the good
nation natured rivalry that exists
between neighborhood neighboring fire
companies that culture also includes
Christmas parties where the children of
the firefighters come for presents and
cookies the way they might go to their
grandparents or other relatives and
includes the annual company picnic where
the kids play with children of other
firefighters the way they would with
cousins at a family picnic and includes
the annual company dance a formal dress
up dinner where the firefighters and
their spouses celebrate their joy and
humor and friendship much like that at a
family wedding the firehouse is
fundamentally a family environment and
as in families there's a code of
behavior that its members are bound to
honor a firefighter is expected to help
with the chores like cleaning into
maintenance just as he expect is
expected to know his duties on the fire
floor or above the fire floor in a fire
he knows where he's expected to be and
he knows the consequences if he isn't
there the firehouse is also about
Brotherhood and a strong unquestioning
relationship between the men and women
in a few Fargo houses if a firefighter
falls into danger in a burning building
there is only the man next to him who
will save his life and that dependence
is the unwritten code that binds them
from his first day as a probationary
firefighter he understands that is the
old guys the veterans the first whips
who keep the job focused and unified who
serve as role models it's easy to spot
them there are always the first to put
themselves forward they are what the
young firefighter hopes to become I
cannot think of a more humbling
experience and to stand among men like
Lee ILP Marty McTeague and Pete Bundy
for they are not only the vessels of our
historical memory but they are also our
leaders knowing this firehouse culture I
fully understand
why they rushed into the towers summon
him with obvious trepidation Pete
biofield left a note for his family
Terry Hatton is said to have met a
friend in the lobby of the North Tower
hugged him and said take care yourself
brother I don't know if I'll ever see
you again
apprehensive or not 343 firefighters 23
police officers in 33 37 Port Authority
officers did not question their duty
what is more difficult to understand is
why they did not come out the media
offers its predictable bromides and has
been telling us daily that we are
changed forever these assertions remind
me of William Butler Yeats who when he
saw that he believed to be a
catastrophic event in 1916 said all this
changed changed utterly and that a
terrible beauty is born but this
provides little comfort and coming to
terms with the profound atrocity we have
lived through the first attack in the
modern era on American soil even in the
best of times we change a little from
day to day here at Ground Zero the scale
of frightfulness is what we must ponder
for it it is it is the greatest warning
the world has ever seen
a warning about the desperate measures
that terrorism is willing to take months
later people still remain incredulous
that September 11th occurred Lea Eppley
has told me actually as recently as four
days ago that he still doesn't believe
it he doesn't believe he will ever never
see a son again or that so many people
have perished or that so many
firefighters are buried in the clouds
even a year from now he says I won't
believe it perhaps others have already
settled the matter in their minds and
take comfort in the closure but I still
struggle to find a settled breath if I
could come to understand why this
happened and why these men were lost
then perhaps all those I have spoken
with during this time could do so as
well but it is so hard finally we all
have to think and speak to ourselves and
as for me I believe that the answers can
come only in the little visits I have
from time to time with my spiritual
connections Americans do not wear their
religion on their sleeves the reasons
for this I think is that our fiercely
independent
but it is also a product of our founding
fathers belief in a society that is
better off when church and state are
separated in my local church recently
the responsorial Psalm was I rejoiced
when I heard them say let us go to the
house of the Lord
I do rejoice when I see people going to
a house of worship anyhow I do not
however advise my children my friends or
anyone else to follow my example people
must do what they feel in their hearts
and what their education and
intelligence prescribe for myself I
believe that having a spiritual texture
to my life
elevates the view of life and the people
around me it gives me patience in a
demanding world helps me to seek a peace
I've often thought that my work as a
firefighter has exposed me to so much of
death and misery that it has tempered my
anger instead of lashing out in sarcasm
and higher as I once did my first
inclination now is to try to understand
the darkness of stupidity and to guide
it towards some kind of light I also try
to recognize that sometimes the stupid
and intransigent one is I I think all
firefighters and all first responders
would gladly suffer with someone if it
would end to suffering
a judeo-christian philosophy sorry our
judeo-christian philosophy urges us to
protect ourselves our family and our
freedoms while at the same time
encouraging us to love our enemies as WH
Auden said in his poem September 1st
1939 we must want we must love one
another or die
the heroic souls listed in the
dedication of this book were living ones
living lives of bravery because they
believed deeply that they were here on
earth to help others to me that's a
truth based on the teaching that we must
do unto others that means would have
them do unto us but the low religions
exposed some version of this idea in a
theological sense it often doesn't
filter into our day-to-day living I know
only this that if the philosophy of
doing unto others truly illuminated all
religions we would have a better world
all writers hope their work to be of
some consequence whether it is fame or
wealth or social change with this book I
simply wanted to record the efforts of
great men and great women books Will
Survive movies television programs and
magazine articles written about the
world today there are so many stories of
courage and Duty among the police
officers and firefighters there are four
hundred and three such stories and there
are also stories of civilian workers in
the towers going dangerously out of
their way to help others even if it were
possible to tell all of them I do not
think I have it in me to relate all of
these stories and in that perhaps I have
failed I know so few of these nearly
3,000 victims yet I feel as if part of
my family has sailed off on a ship never
to return but I've tried to present an
honest and direct account of this awful
time in a sensitive way and I hope that
all the lives that have been lost will
be honored by the stories found here and
that the wives and husbands and parents
and children of the families left behind
will find in these pages the heroism of
their loved ones who no longer share
their dreams though we did not mention
it specifically I think Seamus Haney had
our collective future in
when he wrote no play or poem or song
can fully right or wrong inflicted or
endured history says don't hope on this
side of the grave but then once in a
lifetime the longed-for tidal wave of
justice can rise up and hope in history
rhyme so hope for a great sea change on
the far side of revenge believe that a
furthest shore is reachable from here
believe in miracles and cures and
healing wells I think of these many days
that have passed in September 11th and I
think of all I have seen all I have
heard this awful experience has brought
me closer to everyone I know for the
wonders of friendship and love have
become so much more appreciable now I
hear the voice of love and friendship
and it is the voice of grandpré on zero
it is the voice of kindness and
generosity determination and strength it
is the voice of tragedy sadness and
grief and the voice of inspiration it is
finally the voice of America and that
voice continues to be heard loud and
clear it's about the world thank you
you know take questions now there's a
mic up front here and any questions
mr. Smith maybe one question that hasn't
been answered and the story that
probably hasn't been told yet what
happened between the firefighters on the
line and the fire commissioner thomas
von essen that led to discussion between
these two forces you know it's a very
long story it goes for years this story
and Tommy of Van Essen did all that he
in his power to try to reconcile his
position with the firefighters but you
know he was a union president here in
New York and the day that Rudy Giuliani
offered him the job a commissioner when
he was the president of the Union in the
middle of negotiating a new contract and
he took the job and it was sort of like
passing ships in the night you know he
just went from one ship to the other and
I think the firefighters were very angry
with that very angry and and then after
9/11 that anger began to boil when tommy
said a few unfortunate things but they
were taken out of context after saying
how wonderfully heroic the firefighters
were and what a great job they did and
so on I mean he was very very you know
he's fundamentally and great at he's in
all our firefighters I think like me
over whether you're on the job or not
and somebody said to me you know you
have to be careful what you ask a
fireman's do because he'll you know
he'll really risk his life to do it and
Tommy then said somebody asked him about
criticism in the fart houses and he said
well they should suck it up and it was a
hard thing and and the firefighters
found it to be unforgivable and it's
unfortunate but that's the way it is yes
sir oh I'm just a dog dog that's just in
the ducts Bert about these things and
things but but um but um could you
step-by-step explain to me why
horizontally
tell the powers to buttock Lee because I
knew we will be short times like 40
years ago that those buildings were
built by get you have an opinion about
it and I wrote a big deal about it
actually in the history of the site and
in the construction of these buildings
there is right now the McKenzie company
which is very important company in the
world it's a management evaluation
company is doing a study of why these
buildings fell and doing a study of 911
from A to Z it's a paid-for study they
didn't volunteer to do it it's it I have
very full confidence in the McKenzie
company to rather than go into a long if
you will forgive me rather than go into
a long lecture about construction
processes there are some great
controversies involved in this number
one is that the company that was charged
with putting the fireproofing on the
steel was in litigation from 1974 to
1992 with the Port Authority and the man
who was the president of that company
was said to be a soldier in John Gotti's
Army and that man
the reason the litigation ended in 1992
was that man was found with
multitudinous bullet holes in the
backseat of a car in the basement of the
World Trade Center and so it was sort of
a mob rub out without any doubt and that
was a real controversy involved in the
making of this building once you
consider that whether it's true or not
it was reported in the New York Times
which is why I'm able to say it to you
tonight
that steel if it were unprotected would
stretch at 1200 degrees inherent
temperature and I think that this plane
came into this building so fast about
550 miles an hour's a plane normally
travels about 350 to 400 miles an hour
came so fast into those buildings that
it it entered right through the middle
shafts of the building which controlled
the elevators and the stairwells that
automatically doomed everybody above
because it made the stairwells untenable
he couldn't go to the roof because the
stairwells were now filled with fire and
what it did though was it developed a
comprehensive fire load on the building
comprehensive meaning this is an acre of
flooring each floor in the World Trade
Center was an acre and it was filled
with fire and so consequently the steel
stretched pretty much simultaneously on
all four sides of the building and as it
should this is my idea by the way no one
has done a study yet because you know
half the steel went to the Mafia and the
other half went out to how to her out to
a to a junkyard then it went on to
barges and now it's already sold and
it's gone somewhere and recycled it was
just too fast for my you know for its
own good I think and when it when it
stretched simultaneously it provided for
this building to fall in a pancake
fashion most collapses fall on one side
of the building and it will fall like
this and cantilever against the next
floor or against the building next door
however it does it but this building
fell simultaneously this floor to the
next floor and the floor below it
because of the way the building was
constructed which was it was connected
to the sides of the building rather than
built on top of steel it was connected
the way it that that dynamic weight of
that fall determined that the floor
below it would collapse and then as
as chief J Jonas says it was like a
locomotive that came off the tracks and
was on the theis and you hear his thump
thump thump thump and closer and closer
until it fell down hundred and ten
stories fell down in 12 seconds so
that's really all I want to say about it
right now I feel thank you very much a
couple of couple of things one is thank
you so much and that that video was just
it was a little hard for me to take
again but thank you for that I have two
questions one having to do with Kevin
Shay
I live on 66th Street where his
firehouse was and I thought I had read
that you know he's I'm sure some of the
other firefighters have a survivor guilt
and wondering if he did something wrong
and you know why did he survive and
nobody else did and whether that's
pervasive throughout the department and
the second question has to do more with
the years of experience that were lost
and how you think the fire department
how could how can you possibly recoup
recover from that and all those years
gone they're both very good questions
and they've been asked by reporters from
The Times The New York Times magazine
story did a story on Kevin Shay and I
think it it it treated him unfairly in a
sense that it asked on the cover hero or
coward and you know that was never an
issue in Kevin's mind I know Kevin he's
a very courageous young man
I know his brother who's also a
firefighter in the Bronx and I do think
that he because he has this lapse of
memory that he would like to know why he
was out on the street when others were
in the building and I think that the
until he sort of finds that out to
therapy or however if his memory comes
back it bothers him because so many
people have died but I think that this
is a very genuine concern in his mind
and as I say I think most firefighters
who survive this feel that they are
fortunate and that that the firefighting
is a very dangerous job people die and
you know during my time in the job I was
just trying to add it up the other day
but more than I would say more than 140
people died during my time in the New
York Fire Department and I went to a lot
of funerals
so it's this historical memory that
carries forward and I think that
relieves a lot of attention of survivor
guilt quite frankly the level of
preparedness I think was traumatized a
little and put in shock but I truly
believe that they are now back to their
normal standards of preparedness I think
they have they hired a bunch of probe's
and and new firefighters just to fill
these ranks and they since September
11th there are 700 new people on the job
and they have been changing them like
like mad the expertise level the level
you know in these rescue companies and
these busy truck companies they have I
love a level of expertise that comes
mostly with experience and a lot with
training and that is hard to replace but
yet I know a lot of these firefighters
who are still there you know these great
great firefighters and while we lost the
fire department has always had these
people who are sort of you know legacies
in their time legends I'm sorry legends
in their times and
like like captain Hatton have rescue 1
and patty Brown of ladder 3 and these
just great great firefighters and they
did perish in this fire and so they are
those legends will be hard to replace
but we still have guys like Jack
Pritchard - as a firefighter out in
Brooklyn on the job and there are great
guys around who when you see them like
ray Downey you know they have medals 20
rows of medals on their chest and let me
tell you you see a firefighter with a
lot of medals like that it's not easy to
get a medal in the New York Fire
Department it's just not easy I spent 18
years in the fire department I was in as
many fires as anybody never got a medal
because I was on the engine work because
I was at the end of a nozzle they don't
give people at the end of a nozzle
medals they only give you medals if you
go up the back forest escape and you
carry somebody out but anyway could you
call me I'm sorry could you did you
comment on from your the firefighters
perspective you wrote you read about
going into buildings and the fear that
there's a crack in the in the wall of a
ceiling that might bring the building
down but you to comment on what the
psyche is the firefighter is now after
perhaps revealing what the construction
defects or shortcomings are in modern
skyscrapers how's that going to affect
the firefighters going into buildings
today you know I think it puts a lot of
pressure on the first responding Chiefs
and but if there's a fire in a building
you know just for argument's sake of 60
stories and the fire is on the 55th
floor ultimately and there are people
trapped there ultimately the
responsibility of the firefighter is to
go into that building and go up there
you know you really can't second-guess
the construction of the building but I
think that there will be a lot of
analyses being made in the next couple
of years over the inherent strength of
the steel in these buildings see this
bill
fell down because of the steel it's that
simple and the steel didn't hold the
steel connections didn't hold it came
down faster than anybody had ever
realized when a fire chief goes to a
building and he sees a third alarm fire
on arrival it's a warehouse downtown
it's a huge fire so he calls 30 fire
trucks there he's got a hundred and
fifty men working well sides of this
building he's got people right near the
walls you know inside up near the roof
he knows that this building generally
will last for three hours before there
is a real problem of collapse inevitably
there will be a problem of collapse when
a building burns it's just it's
inevitable it's a physical law as you
weaken the steel it will collapse unless
you extinguish the fire this building
was the was the these two buildings were
the only two buildings of their kind
built in New York City they were built
against the wishes of John T o'hagan who
was then the fire commissioner and the
chief of Department simultaneous the
youngest chief of Department in the
history of the New York Fire Department
an absolutely brilliant
man and and a fire engineer he was very
against the building of these buildings
but of course they were built within the
purview of the Port Authority and the
Port Authority is exempt from local laws
and the and and so they got built over
the objections of the fire department
now there's another interesting thing
about how these buildings got built that
that the the Chase Manhattan Bank made a
real commitment to one Chase Plaza down
there and they built that building up
Zeckendorf built it for them they built
it up they spent you know hundreds of
millions of dollars whatever it was well
that's an exaggeration maybe maybe they
spent you know 60 or 70 million dollars
put this building up and all of a sudden
people started moving out of Wall Street
and going up to midtown Manhattan that's
another interesting why are these big
buildings only downtown and in midtown
Manhattan because that's the way
Manhattan schist folds it folds up in
Midtown and down and then up in downtown
New York and you can only build these
big
buildings on Manhattan schist so when
Rockefeller realized that once one Chase
Manhattan Plaza was was financially in
jeopardy
because all of the surrounding buildings
were moving uptown the viability of what
the Wall Street area was going to reduce
the property values right he went to his
brother to help and who was his brother
but the governor of the state of New
York and the governor of the state of
New York got together the commissioners
of the Port Authority and his brother
David who was the chairman they said
look we have a great idea let's build
the World Trade Center down in the Wall
Street area and that will revitalize the
economic center of New York and it will
become not New York's Trade Center not
the state's Trade Center it will be the
World Trade Center and that is the
concept that they had that this would
then become the financial capital of the
world
and you know they were right actually I
don't fault them for doing this it was a
smart thing but it only got done because
David Rockefeller happened to be
chairman the Chase Manhattan Bank and
Nelson Rockefeller was the governor of
the state of New York but these are the
dynamics of life in our country you know
there is this funny connection between
government and financial interests and
hopefully now as this lower area of
Manhattan has to be rebuilt the same
connection will work but it will work in
the best interest of all New Yorkers and
certainly in the best interest of the
families of the 2,800 people who died
down there because they have a horse and
cart problem and the horse and cart
problem is that they have to deal with
this memorial before they're going to be
able to center on a rebuilding program
down there and they have not been able
to present a sensible plan to the
Committees of the victims and there are
now six individual committees
representing those 2,800 people it's
hi thank you for writing this book thank
you
I have two questions one is who
authorized the bunker in the World Trade
Center complex and the other one is who
authorized the sale of this steel
I would I would have to say Rudy
Giuliani and you know the bunker was in
my mind a funny concept to begin with
particularly when you put it on the 7th
floor of a building that that really
where that you know actually there's a
wonderful building where that bunker
should have been the old police
headquarters I happen to be on the board
of a art school here in New York and the
owners of that building were trying
desperately to get us to relocate our
art school to the bottom of the old
police headquarters which was in the
which is in the village you know in
Little Italy beautiful old building and
that's where that bunker should have
been quite frankly if they needed a
bunker and that it was in the 7th floor
was a mistake in that I and that came
from the Office of Emergency Management
it was a mistake from the very beginning
and and Giuliani has got a you know I
suppose he's responsible for that and as
is he is also responsible for the other
side of your question which you'll have
to remind me what it was I know he was
responsible for both
the sale of the steel now that to me if
I could say something about that to me
an engineering firm a really reliable
prestigious consulting firm should have
been hired the second or third week
after the fall of these towers to
reconstruct the the the events of 9/11
but it they did not that that
engineering firm Mackenzie and company
was only hired at a month ago and all
these intervening months there was no
investigation at all and during this
period of time the steel went well you
know some of it as you know ended up in
the Long Island junkyards that were
owned by connected people or at least it
was implied in the New York Times they
were connected people and and some of
that steel got went on barges a lot of
that steel went on barges and went
sailing down the river to the places
like Pennsylvania where it was you know
recycled now that steel could have told
the story and I was quite amazed when I
found this out by the way I was very
amazed when I found this out because
when an aircraft goes down the FAA comes
up and they reconstruct that airplane I
mean when that plane went into the water
right outside of the Hamptons several
years ago they dove into that ocean for
months and months and months until they
got enough of that airplane out of that
water to reconstruct it in a hangar and
that cost millions and millions of
dollars how come they never tried to do
that here but why didn't they locate the
steel all that steel was numbered you
know and it was configured that not
those numbers were burnt into the steel
they could have configured the steel in
the 80th floor and to the hundred and
tenth floor it wasn't you know it wasn't
anything but an expense but yet they
didn't do it and they didn't do it I
think because they didn't think of it
why they didn't think of it I don't know
we're gonna take one more question here
and then Dennis will be available to
personalize books they're also the books
are in the lobby out for sale some of
them are pre signed so if you just want
to move through that like that well
we'll take this one last question
hi uh had we had the good fortune that
day of the towers not falling how with
the fire department have fought that
friar and how long can you guess that it
would have taken I mean you said the
good men who have up on a 23rd will
exhaust you yeah
rightfully so I think what they would
have done you know fire burns up and I
think the Chiefs would have ultimately
said it's too dangerous we've lost
everybody on top of this fire they the
police department considered putting
helicopter helicopters on the roofs but
the thermal column from the fire was too
great they couldn't do that they know
that the stairs were out they figured
the stairs were out there was nobody on
the roof and on either roof and so I
think that ultimately they would have
said everybody out and let the fire burn
and it would burn up and then ultimately
after it burned up for those 20 stories
of 25 stories somebody would have gone
up there with a hose line and they would
have controlled the safety you know they
would have managed the safety aspects of
it that's the way I think it would but
you know I quite frankly I'm a backstep
firefighter and you've asked me a
question that really should be asked of
the chief of Department as a guy who
really knows what he's doing
in terms of managing great fires let me
just take this last one if I couldn't
yes sir oh you are would you share with
us how you're possibly coping with the
emotions from this experience the
firefighters are me yourself well I'll
tell you I find it difficulty at time I
can't watch that tape I could watch it
the first time it was very difficult I
tried to watch it a second time and I
couldn't and so I can't watch it but I
do think it should be should be seen do
you know what I mean and somebody said
well maybe it's taking advantage of
people because it is poignant and then I
realized the reason I can't watch it is
because I personally know so many of
those people who were lost and so that's
very difficult for me
the other side of it the other side of
it is that I think I feel pretty
dedicated to what I'm now doing which is
telling the story
and that sustains me in many ways and
I'm very involved in New York police and
fire widows and children's fund that
sustains me and I think you know it's a
little like make light of it but it's a
little like having a young teenager in
the house you got to keep him scheduled
you know and if you keep them scheduled
you'll be able to keep them out of
trouble and I feel the same way about
emotional problems that if you if people
are suffering emotionally from this
great difficulty it's better to keep
them occupied and I see that in some of
my close friends who have lost children
or brothers or fathers that they're more
occupied they keep themselves the better
off they are and then I think time is a
great relief I want to thank you all for
coming out this evening